[Musique]
mon terrain de jeu c'est Besançon en
fait j'y suis né
je resterai définitivement
que mes études aussi
mes études à la Faculté des Lettres 300
mètres plus loin j'ai fait le début de
ma vie aux archives départementales
encore 200 et plus loin j'ai terminé à
la ville de Besançon comme conseiller et
conservateur encore 100 mètres plus loin
donc je suis un grand voyageur devant
cette éternité byzantine parce que quand
on voit ce qui est ce qui est devant
nous là
c'est c'est 2000 ans plus de 2000 ans
d'histoire
[Musique]
le soir Castan c'est un endroit
merveilleux parce que c'est un
magnifique morceau de nature dans la
ville et ça ça ne peut que toucher
j'ai là vraiment de très vieux souvenirs
quand j'étais vraiment enfant et un
gardien à l'époque il y avait toujours
des gardiens qu'on employait pour pour
faire visiter et les gardiens de
manquaient pas d'imagination parce que
nous est rentrés par un petit escalier
qui était là on traversait tout ce sol
et alors il faisait revivre et il
sacrifiait les chrétiens avec des lions
qui étaient dans une fausse là dessous
qui soit invraisemblable mais c'était
quand même quelques un grand moment
d'histoire propre à émerveiller les
enfants
[Musique]
la beauté d'une ville en fait tient à la
qualité à l'ampleur de ces monuments
mais également
assez sorte de pas de côté que le
visiteur peut faire en poussant une
porte et en découvrant l'intimité des
usages que
les habitants ont pu en faire et là on a
comme ça à Besançon ces escaliers qui
vont du 16ème siècle à la fin du 19e et
on voit les gens monter descendre les
escaliers et les habitants ce elle est
et moi je suis toujours très touché par
par ces décors cette ville est
admirablement protégée et que jusque
dans les moindres détails rien n'a bougé
[Musique]
c'est un endroit un peu miraculeux pour
celui qui depuis qu'il est petit est
amoureux de sa ville
j'ai lu en particulier à l'époque le
vieux Besançon Gaston requis cette
façade telle qu'elle était parce que
cette façade pharmacie qui date de plus
de 200 ans 250 ans et en fait qui avait
disparu au début du 20e siècle au moment
des grandes inondations et rien ne nous
permettait d'imaginer qu'on allait
pouvoir la retrouver et pour et pour les
gens comme moi qui qui assiste à cette
reconstitution à se rétablissement comme
ce jeu de construction historique c'est
quelque chose d'absolument d'absolument
incroyable et qui n'arrive je crois à
casser peu souvent dans une dans une vie
d'amateur
[Musique]
un enfant comme celui que j'ai été qui
venait ici en 6e et qui était passionné
par l'histoire ne pouvait peut-être que
lui par ce raccourci de l'histoire en
fait qui voilà remontait toute la grande
rue arrivait devant cette perspective
incroyable avec le clocher de Saint-Jean
ça rappelait déjà stadal le rouge et le
noir et puis toute cette place sur
laquelle une quantité de personnalité de
Victor Hugo à Flaubert au frères Lumière
à Charles Nodier était venu donc
vraiment un grand moment puis la beauté
de cet endroit
comme souvent dans le reste de la ville
où on a à la fois l'architecture et
au-delà dans les perspectives la nature
environnante ça c'est quelque chose de
très très merveilleux ici à Besançon
que je suis une espèce de
[Musique]
dinosaures des temps anciens
de consultera peut-être pas en tout cas
ma fierté à moi c'est d'avoir écrit
beaucoup souvent et et ça les livres
c'est pour l'éternité